[Applause]
[Music]
every time a latin-american government
tries to discuss foreign policy and
development they end up discussing
regional integration that is why we
should understand the three main common
features of all art in America football
that soccer few Americans revolutions
and the regional organizations seriously
we're really not kidding here in the
last few decades there have been so many
regional organizations that it is almost
impossible to know what goals each of
them have besides obviously being an
excuse for spending money on public
workers headquarters and traveling
these are UNICEF Mercosur al-baqarah
COMSOL AK Aldi the MDM community seeker
seller the Rio group and of course the
Organization of American States and to
be honest I'm probably not even
mentioning all of them there anyway once
you hear about all of these
organizations you might be thinking the
Latin America is the place where people
get on with each other the best a place
where it's really easy to do business
among the different countries and where
governments work together for the common
good in some sort of wonderful paradise
right where all the bad news is if you
didn't guess that none of that is true
all of these organizations they were
born with these really wonderful high
ideas but we could say they all really
did nothing for development and economic
and political integration in Latin
America new institutions are created but
it isn't clear what to do with the
previous ones it is an endless fight
forward carlos Malamud
look despite all the different processes
of integration trade is strangely low
among these different countries
the numbers are important here the share
of exports inside the region it hasn't
changed much and it has been around 20%
which is much lower than in other parts
of the world this is pretty strong
evidence about how artificial and
unproductive these organizations are
[Music]
we will see the details of this case
though the word disappointment or
failure would probably better describe
Mercosur but I can already tell you that
it is very possible that this lack of
real integration is the origin of some
of the most important problems that the
region is facing the eternal promise
Latin America is do viewers it's a
fantastic region it's got great natural
resources it has significant
biodiversity and its climate is varied
and impressive many people would say
that the region is one of the most
beautiful on earth
however economically speaking things are
not looking so great despite all of
these magnificent resources and its
great potential the region has been left
behind in terms of economic growth let's
compare for example the current richest
country in Latin America and that would
be Chile so I think most people would
agree here that Chile's done a pretty
good job in the last few decades right
well despite that apparent progress just
have a look at this chart
[Music]
now here we have taken the richest
country in Latin America and they've
compared it to South Korea which is not
even the richest country in eastern Asia
bands well the difference is pretty
obvious in the 60s Chile was a poor
country but was far richer than South
Korea they well things they're rather
different we can also look at Argentina
which was once the richest country in
Latin America with the exception of Cuba
but now take a look at its evolution
when compared to Spain well one of the
causes for this lower growth might
precisely be the low trade integration
and the excess protectionism and
bureaucracy that the region has always
suffered from I mean there are loads of
agreements there are tons of committees
and forums and all of that stuff but
when the rubber hits the road
there's really nothing there but do hold
on for just one second because a few
years ago a new integration project it
was put into place and this one is
actually completely different to the
rest not only is it the first project
with real success in the region but it
might also change the destiny of Latin
America forever and here we're talking
about the Pacific Alliance
[Music]
the Pacific Alliance
in April of 2011 our friends Chile
Colombia Mexico and Peru formed the so
called Pacific Alliance its mission is
to finally achieve an integration so the
goods capital and people can move freely
around the region
all of this was put in place with the
idea that it would stimulate growth
development and competitiveness in these
economies our countries account for 55%
of Latin American exports this is not a
romantic integration of poetic
integration it is a realistic
integration before the world and to the
world Alan Garcia former president of
Peru
man so they did even though there's
still a lot of work to be done since
then developments it's been really
significant in only six years these four
countries have removed 92 percent of
custom tariffs and they've set a
deadline to remove all of the rest as
well along with this they've simplified
the bureaucracy of customs and
administration especially when it comes
to rules about the origin of goods this
was previously a significant burden on
the region all right so up until now if
a Colombian producer used Peruvian
supplies he couldn't take advantage of
the free trade agreements between
Colombia and Mexico when selling his
goods to Mexico which is just crazy but
that's not the end of it visa
requirements they've also been
eliminated so the movements of visitors
has actually doubled and then and this
is very important there have been
significant advances in financial
integration these four countries have
created the mi la the American
integrated market which is meant to be
the largest stock market in Latin
America
[Music]
and all there's more among other
initiatives the countries in the
Alliance are working together in order
to be known in international markets
they have also started to share
embassies in African and Asian countries
and they have decided to negotiate all
together for their free trade agreements
for example they've actually already
started to do this with New Zealand
Australia Canada and Singapore Australia
and New Zealand start trade talks with
Pacific Alliance in other words these
four countries are building step-by-step
a unique market which will be rather
significance we're talking about two
hundred and fourteen million consumers
here with a combined GDP which makes
this alliance one of the eight largest
economies in the world
[Music]
this is an economy that represents 50%
of all exports and more than 40% of all
foreign investment in Latin America we
could say that if the Pacific Alliance
keeps it up in a very short time we
might have to consider it the biggest
power in Latin America but in order to
understand a bit better the achievements
that they've had in only six years we
should look at the other large group in
the region and that would be Marcus or
the downfall of Mercosur Marcus or it
was created in 1991 by Brazil Argentina
Uruguay and Paraguay with the intention
of creating one large integrated market
well these were ambitious goals that the
advances have been pretty damn modest
and how about some evidence of this well
just have a look at this the trade among
Mercosur our members represents today
less than 13% of the total trade of its
members in 1995 that was almost 20
percent so rather than encouraging trade
between its members we could say that
Marcos or has actually weakened them in
the last few years Marcos orb has become
some sort of protectionist shield rather
than something which is working to
integrate these countries further not
exactly what they wanted in the first
place the group has become little more
than an anti gringo talking shop but why
isn't this working
well that's mainly because the countries
they're not really very committed in
theory Marcos or is a process of
economic integration but there are so
many exceptions and restrictions that in
the end there's no free movement of
goods or services America saw has become
something which is totally ineffective
look a good example can be found on the
border of Argentina and Uruguay in
theory the goods should be able to move
freely between both countries however
the reality is totally different when
adding customs inspections and
bureaucracy a truck from Uruguay to
Argentina could be delayed for more than
24 hours which is totally crazy when
it's supposed to not be delayed at all
all of this has led to Uruguay formally
asking to become a member of the Pacific
Alliance and there is more to this story
still the political change in Argentina
and Brazil has led to both of their
governments accepting that burkas or at
least as it is understood today is
almost completely worthless will never
reach the common market the custom union
is completely destroyed and the free
trade area is not working either
Mercosur is in a dying State Danny Louis
story Minister of Economy in Uruguay
this is why Macri has decided to become
closer to the Pacific Alliance and look
for ties between both processes of
integration the real question becomes
now will the Pacific Alliance create a
change in Marcos or if it does then that
would be great news for the entire
region the Pacific boomers
and now of course the question that we
have to ask is well why is the Pacific
Alliance unlike any of those other
organizations the only one that seems to
be working well maybe this has to do
with the so-called Pacific coomer's
Chile Peru Colombia and Mexico these
countries have been the most dynamic
economies in Latin America and they
share the same vision they all agree
that in order to grow and develop they
have to produce and do business with the
rest of the world and this is why
according to the World Bank these humans
are the country where it is easiest to
do business or where more trade
agreements assigned with the rest of the
world
[Music]
anyway the Pacific Alliance represents
one of the best opportunities for Latin
American to be in a position to become
the talk of the town it wouldn't even be
too much of a stretch to say that we
could be witnessing the birth of a great
economic power but now it's your turn
do you think Latin America has to bet on
these processes of integration well
leave us your opinion in the comments
below as well as in this Quick Poll also
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
for brand new videos every Monday and
every Thursday also do not forget to
check out our friends at the reconsider
media podcast if they provided the
vocals in this episode that are not mine
and as always thank you for watching
[Music]